every single thing that exists out there
inside of the Matrix is done so with a
purpose Andrew Tate was already one of
the most Googled people in the world the
former kickboxer had curated a social
media profile celebrating fast cars
private jets money and masculinity
banned from Twitter in 2017 this year he
had accounts removed from Instagram
Facebook YouTube and Tick Tock one hand
the reason repeated misogyny saying
women bear some responsibility for rape
and acting out violence against females
[Music]
machete boom in her face and grip her up
by the neck
on Thursday night Romanian police
detained Tate his younger brother
Tristan and two other men they say the
arrests are part of a nine-month
investigation into alleged human
trafficking rape and forming an
organized crime gang involving two
British and two Romanian citizens
the police say six women were sexually
exploited by the Gang
Tate appeared to blame a conspiracy of
Elites he calls The Matrix The Matrix
has attacked me on Tuesday Tate used his
recently reactivated Twitter account to
taunt the climate activist Greta tunberg
about the emissions of his claimed 33
cars a day later she suggested he use an
email address to Enlighten her one that
mocked his self-professed masculinity
he responded with a video that featured
pizza boxes from a Romanian restaurant
some speculated that was how Romanian
authorities confirmed his whereabouts
but reports in the Romanian media said
police had used a number of methods
including social media posts to ensure
both brothers were in the country Tates
home for the last five years
among the items found out that home were
bundles of cash and weapons including
swords knives and firearms
a court in Bucharest has ruled that all
four suspects be detained for a further
30 days
Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera